thinking you can't get through a day
without one of us here reporting on yet
another mass shooting well you are on to
something because that is the reality
here in this country there have been 162
mass shootings in the U.S so far this
year alone according to the gun violence
archive and our kids are noticing how
could they not according to the latest
CBS News poll gun violence is a top
worry among kids six and ten in fact say
it's a major concern something on their
minds and it's on the very same list as
you find more common teenage concerns
like bullying and academic performance
now how to deal with it well more than
60 percent of Americans are in favor of
an outright ban on AR-15 semi-automatic
rifles that's the type of gun used in
school shootings in Nashville and Uvalde
and so many other places